[Applause]
oh my god please welcome my mom from etd
walmart
[Applause]
oh my
oh my god
first of all your kimono is everything
and i love it so much thank you and i'm
just so happy to see you you know you
gave me the book i remember it so well
the velveteen rabbit
and i
literally love that book and you're so
associated with it and i think about it
all the time and
you're so ever present with me and in
that book and and just all the things
how have you been i've been awesome i've
been great um still working doing a lot
of films
and
i have a whole healing practice as you
know
where i teach people about self-love oh
well and come by
thank you
it's about to be the 40th anniversary of
e.t i mean literally it's happening
[Applause]
again
can you believe it you look so hot
look at that
that was the first day on the set and
i'm sitting in this really high
director's chair
and drew comes up to me and she says
hi i'm going to sit on your lap now
and i said well come on up true i mean i
knew you were going to be a director
producer
back then
really oh
for sure um are are you gonna watch the
movie for the 40th anniversary and have
a little nostalgia reminisce of course
we're we're all going to be there aren't
we i remember when you showed up in like
halloween and you were you were sexy we
were all like oh wow mom's sexy
you have that little cat outfit on i
still fit in it too oh i bet you
you are giving me goals
and is it true that you saw a steven
spielberg jump on top of an et costume
that was on fire yeah i don't remember
that no i don't think you weren't on the
set
uh
something happened in the one of the
costumes caught on fire one day and
everybody froze
they went
ah
and stephen went hoo
yeah just here's a fun fact um steven
um my daughter frankie um who's there
she's obsessed with him and it's so cute
and he'll send her videos and the other
day she asked him like we found out that
that jaws nickname was bruce
and um oh you didn't know that i didn't
and guess what bruce was his lawyer
how awesome is that i think it's pretty
apropos
exactly
it's synonymous with the profession um
well i i really like um from what i
remember e.t um was kept alive on set at
all times i mean i i would go have lunch
with e.t a lot i saw the wires i knew
the deal i was like
do not believe that for a moment but i i
do not know drew barrymore
we
found you one day and they would put e.t
in a corner
when he wasn't working and
and we found drew and she's over there
just talking to him
and from that time on
stephen had two guys on et at all times
so that any time you went over to talk
to him
his eyes
could work and his head could go up and
down and he could respond to you
i got to tell you this story do you
remember
filming et's death scene oh god yes
and do you remember me coming over to
pick you up to do it yes
yes and stephen got it got me to cry oh
no
okay
so this is how it went down so
being the mother that i am with all the
kids that i work with i
you were on an adjoining sound
soundstage
and i went over
and i said okay drew
now we're going to go shoot the scene
where e.t is dying
but you know he's not really dying
sweetheart he's acting just like we are
okay
and you looked at me and you said
i know dee do you think i'm stupid
[Laughter]
so i picked you up we walked into the
set you took one look at it it went
[Applause]
you were always so kind to me i'm so
thrilled that you would come here today
and grace us with your presence and tell
us these stories and this is just
such a fortunate moment for myself thank
you everybody who's like bearing witness
to it z wallace she is an author and you
can pick up her book
born giving birth to a new you which is
now available
[Music]
you